tim stewart is the president of the u.s
gas and oil association we're honored to
be joined by him tonight tim thanks so
much uh for coming on so
you know to someone who's not in the
business as you are selling off an asset
like this and allowing it to be sold to
china seems like criminal honestly
you know tucker you articulate it better
than just about anybody i the the
question i think to answer that question
we have to ask ourselves how did we get
here in the first place how did we
replace one bad policy with another bad
policy how did we go from being the the
world's energy superpower being number
one in oil and gas and coal and and
geothermal and second in wind and solar
to shaking the tin cup to the saudis and
and not even being able to track where
where our strategic petroleum reserve
releases end up it's it's really quite
it's it's quite disconcerting isn't it
i i would say
it's really important to know that the
the exploration production companies
were not supportive of the strategic
plutonium reserve release why didn't we
just why weren't we allowed just open up
the spigot of what we're already doing
versus shutting that off and and tapping
into the nation's credit card it really
is it's quite frustrating i got to be
honest i've talked to most of people who
run the oil and gas companies they all
act like you know they're selling
cigarettes to kids they're always a
little bit embarrassed oh it's oil and
gas but really worry about green energy
why don't they step up in public and say
without us this is an impoverished
country this is central africa you need
us in order to stay solvent
and like make some noise and fight back
well we and we're trying to you know
that that tweet that the president sent
out on on saturday was we had a response
where you know how it is you know
twitter's sort of an exercise in
futility there are thousands and
thousands of people who think that
they're experts in oil and gas because
they re-wet they retweet something that
some celebrity does
and and so we've avoided it but we we
saw that tweet come across and and it
just sort of struck a nerve and so we we
did our best to kind of call call the bs
on on the white house and say look
somebody's got to go back and look at
economics here
yeah i mean we i mean it is over if we
get rid of fossil fuels that's just true
and i wish we could stop lying about it
tim stewart i appreciate you're coming
on tonight thank you
thanks for having me on
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight